2050 l'organizzazione mondiale della
sanità ci dice che nel 2050
una persona su tre sarà affetta da
malattia di alzheimer
uno su tre è un numero enorme è un
numero enorme ci spaventa perché forse
nessuna patologia come la malattia di
alzheimer colpisce l'individuo fin nella
sua essenza più intima il malato di
alzheimer non è più in grado di
riconoscere i propri cari non è in grado
di ricordare gli eventi belli della
propria vita non si rende nemmeno tanto
bene conto di che cosa sta succedendo
intorno
e allora che cosa dobbiamo fare
che cosa dobbiamo fare io sono una
scienziata sono neuroscienziata dirigo
l'istituto di neuroscienze del cnr e i
miei laboratori sono in humanitas dove
c'è un meraviglioso gruppo di
collaboratori che lavora insieme a me e
studio la sinapsi che cos'è la sinapsi
la sinapsi è il sito dove avviene il
trasferimento di informazione
all'interno del cervello rappresenta il
cuore e il centro di comando è lì che
avviene tutto ed è lì che vengono quei
processi che vengono chiamati di
plasticità ne abbiamo visto un esempio
meraviglioso poco fa la plasticità
sinaptica che rappresenta la base
strutturale e delle funzioni superiori
l'apprendimento la memoria ma la sinapsi
e è piena di proteine e le proteine sono
codificate da geni e ogni tanto nei geni
c'è qualcosa che non funziona ci può
essere una mutazione e quando c'è una
mutazione allora può esserci una
malattia del cervello
adesso le chiamiamo synaptop ati e
malattie della sinapsi e l'autismo la
schizofrenia sono synaptop ati e ma
anche la malattia di alzheimer
in auto katia perché la sinapsi la prima
struttura che viene a essere colpita
dalla malattia
ci sono varie forme di malattia di
alzheimer esiste non forme genetiche e
quindi fanno parte di quel gruppo di
situazioni in cui qualcosa è andato
storto
nei nostri geni lì non c'è molto che
possiamo fare
però poi esistono una grossa quantità
forse sono la grande maggioranza di
forme sporadiche non si sa esattamente
perché ci siano queste forme perché una
persona un certo punto sviluppa
alzheimer in assenza di una mutazione
genetica
noi non sappiamo questa cosa però
sicuramente c'è qualcosa che accomuna
tutte le forme di malattia di alzheimer
quelle genetiche quelle sporadiche e
dell infiammazione perché anche il
cervello può avere una situazione di
infiammazione questa è una cosa che
magari uno non penserebbe e ci sono
addirittura delle cellule specializzate
nel nostro cervello che si chiamano
cellule micro gliali queste cellule
micro viali sono bellissime vedete hanno
una forma stupenda hanno tutte queste
ramificazioni e sono in pole sentinelle
del cervello quando nel cervello avviene
qualcosa di sbagliato una lesione un
trauma qualcosa
le cellule miei cordiali si attivano
cambiano la loro forma ritraggono tutte
queste ramificazioni cominciano a
viaggiare a cercare di fagocitare e
risolvere la situazione di danno e
questo avviene in effetti anche nella
timer perché questa è una situazione che
noi vediamo normalmente per molti anni
noi abbiamo pensato che la problematica
maggiore nel cervello di pazienti di
alzheimer fosse dovuta a queste
strutture che vedete che sono di
frammenti di proteina beta amiloide che
si accumulano all'interno del cervello
fanno come una collana che si avvolge su
se stessa e stalli tra un neurone e
l'altro ed aumentano aumentano e a un
certo punto e cervello non ce la fa più
e si pensava che questo fosse il
problema ma adesso invece sappiamo che
probabilmente il primo danno
è proprio un danno che viene svolto da
parte di piccole molecole piccoli
gruppetti come se fossero due o tre
perle isolate che attaccano la sinapsi e
ne bloccano il funzionamento e e questo
è l'aspetto importante è quello che noi
abbiamo scoperto nel nostro laboratorio
pochi anni fa e che le cellule micro
gliali e quindi l'infiammazione perché
le cellule nei propria lì sono in grado
quando fagocitano le sostanze strane
anche la beta amiloide una sostanza
estranea bene mentre fagocitano queste
sostanze strane cercando di far pulizia
cominciano a rilasciare sostanze si
chiamano citochine infiammatorie che
generano una situazione nel cervello di
infiammazione che alla lunga alla lunga
diventa dannoso che cos'è che possiamo
fare al momento non abbiamo farmaci che
curino la malattia di alzheimer
abbiamo si vede farmaci che trattano i
sintomi ma non sono in grado di curare
la malattia non sono in grado di
bloccare la morte dei neuroni non sono
in grado di bloccare il danno alla
sinapsi di cui vi ho appena raccontato
e allora cosa possiamo fare noi non
abbiamo via d'uscita due cose possiamo
fare la prima è un compito che abbiamo
noi ricercatori ed è quello di cercare
di lavorare nei nostri laboratori per
cercare di identificare i meccanismi
molecolari alla base della malattia
perché se noi identifichiamo i
meccanismi molecolari allora possiamo
essere in grado di trovare dei farmaci
che siano mirati a colpire ea bloccare
questo processo
se io ho identificato che la micro glia
è in grado di favorire la formazione di
queste specie di queste perle che sono
tossiche
beh allora io posso cercare di fare
costruire dei farmaci che mi blocchino
questo processo
quindi questo è uno scopo un ruolo una
cosa che dobbiamo fare a carico nostro
ma come individui che cos'è che dobbiamo
fare
possiamo fare qualcosa si di fatto
possiamo fare qualcosa perché possiamo
adottare delle strategie di prevenzione
e questa cosa un po ci stupisce la
prevenzione ma come le malattie del
cervello la micro glia l'amiloide tutta
questa confusione
ma come faccio a prevenire io sono
abituato a pensare di poter prevenire
una malattia cardiovascolare a poter
prevenire attraverso delle abitudini
degli stili di vita
posso cercare di prevenire una malattia
metabolica il diabete ma l'alzheimer
in realtà si è la cosa dell'a20
interessante è che sono le stesse
abitudini di vita che prevengono
l'insorgenza di una malattia
cardiovascolare
le stesse sono anche in grado di
rallentare se non prevenire di
rallentare l'insorgenza della malattia
di alzheimer e oggi la scienza ci dice
perché quali sono i motivi per cui
questo avviene una buona dieta sappiamo
che una dieta non a mantenere una dieta
sana è importante per il nostro
organismo ma importante per il nostro
cervello perché se noi adottiamo dei
cibi che abbiano per esempio un forte
una forte capacità anti infiammatoria la
curcuma per esempio è una delle più
famose o delle capacità antiossidanti il
tè verde i frutti rossi mirtilli o delle
capacità neuroprotettive il pesce
azzurro per esempio le noci le noci sono
assolutamente un toccasana per il
cervello
e allora noi possiamo ridurre il carico
infiammatorio del nostro cervello e
quindi questo potrebbe funzionare e
perché l'attività fisica perché adesso
noi sappiamo che attraverso l'attività
fisica aerobica svolta in maniera
regolare
noi aumentiamo nel nostro cervello alla
produzione di un fattore neurotrofico il
più famoso sica è il bdnf brain derived
neurotrophic factor e cosa fa stupì dnf
il bdnf facilita la formazione delle
sinapsi in qualche modo rendi circuiti
più plastici più in grado di andare
incontro ai processi di plasticità di
cui avete appena visto un esempio
meraviglioso ed infine perché diciamo
che dobbiamo sempre mantenere attivo il
nostro cervello perché quando noi
manteniamo attivi il nostro cervello
siamo in grado di aumentare la
formazione delle sinapsi di rendere il
nostro cervello più plastico di iniziare
a formare quella che viene definita
riserva cognitiva
ok
va bene la scienza ci dice questo ma ma
è vero funziona e la risposta è sì
funziona vi racconto solo un esempio che
è stato svolto nell'istituto che ho
l'onore di dirigere alcuni anni fa a
pisa grazie all'intuizione di lamberto
maffei
un gruppo di anziani che erano affetti
dal cosiddetto mile cog ni tv internet
cioè da quella fase in cui uno si
comincia a dimenticare il nome del
vicino di casa non si ricorda più dove
ha parcheggiato la macchina le chiavi
tre ore la mattina per trovare le chiavi
della macchina prima di uscire beh
questa può essere una forma prodromica
della malattia ma non può anche essere
che non succeda niente magari è solo
stress
quindi non ci preoccupiamo però che cosa
ha fatto lamberto maffei e il suo gruppo
hanno preso questi pazienti è un gruppo
di questi sono stati sottoposti a un
treni di tipo fisico e cognitivo tre
volte la settimana lo facevano tutti
insieme quindi c'era anche una bella
componente di tipo conviviale dopo sette
mesi sono andati a vedere che cosa era
successo al gruppo dei pazienti trattati
e al gruppo dei controlli
allora i pazienti trattati dopo sette
mesi nessuno ha virato a malattia di
alzheimer ma anzi il 50 per cento ha
mostrato dei miglioramenti che erano
visualizzabili attraverso tecniche di
risonanza magnetica e di tecniche di
tipo analisi di tipo neuropsicologico il
gruppo di controllo invece il 50 per
cento era andato incontro a un ulteriore
peggioramento
allora si può prevenire ma a questo
punto la domanda è quando ma perché
allora dovrei cominciare a prevenire a
50 anni quando comincia a dimenticarmi
dove ho messo le chiavi della macchina
abbiamo visto abbiamo visto la storia di
mario è bellissima il nostro cervello e
plastico all'inizio della vite più siamo
giovani e più e plastico e allora
cominciamo a mantenere ad avere degli
stili di vita corretti che possano
comunque aumentare la nostra capacità di
reagire alla malattia attraverso delle
regole che sono molto semplici la prima
per esempio evitare al massimo i
traumatismi cerebrali perché le botte i
colpi che uno può prendere alla testa
possono favorire
è pazzesco ma possono favorire
l'insorgenza delle malattie
neurodegenerative probabilmente perché
si instaura una situazione di
infiammazione una dieta sana
un'attività fisica regolare che si svaga
svolta su base regolare e soprattutto
non smettiamo mai di imparare di leggere
di essere curiosi di imparare uno
strumento imparare una lingua di
costruire questa riserva cognitiva che
alla fine non è altro che un patrimonio
di parole di significati che se non sono
sufficienti a far bloccare l'insorgenza
della malattia quantomeno la ritardano e
quantomeno ne riducono tantissimo i
danni cognitivi i danni che possono
esserci più tardi e vorrei finire con un
ultimo messaggio che uno tutto sommato
non si aspetterebbe sapete che questa
prevenzione noi possiamo iniziare
addirittura prima della nascita e noi lo
sappiamo perché sappiamo che quello che
avviene durante la gravidanza poi
influenza in maniera importante la
possibilità poi di ammalare nella vita
adulta e non è un caso non è un caso che
il periodo della gravidanza su un
periodo in cui l'individuo è protetto in
cui la mamma la salute della mamma e
particolarmente tenuta sotto controllo
noi sappiamo che magari infezioni questo
è il motivo per cui cerchiamo di
prevenirle possono causare qualcosa che
non va nella prole
ma cos'è che noi pensiamo normalmente a
malattie del loro sviluppo pensiamo a
malattie dell'infanzia ma in realtà oggi
la ricerca ci dice che quello che
avviene nella vita prenatale puoi
influenzare addirittura la possibilità
di avere this di sviluppare malattia di
alzheimer se nella nostra prole 70 anni
dopo è una cosa che se ci pensate ha
dell'incredibile
però anche delle fortissime potenzialità
a delle fortissime potenzialità noi
sappiamo che un attivazione del sistema
immunitario nella mamma può causare un
accumulo soprattutto se viene ripetuta
diciamo anche durante la vita può
causare un accumulo di proteina beta
amiloide quella famosa collana di cui
raccontavo prima nel cervello del del
figlio dopo 70 anni
questo però ci spaventa un po perché
insomma io poi si ok posso cercare di
evitare l'esposizione evitare fattori di
rischio però più di un tanto non è che
posso fare però considerate questo punto
di vista ha provato a vederla girare
ragionamento se qualcosa di brutto
durante la gravidanza può in qualche
modo influenzare la capacità di ammalare
quando sono grande quando sono adulto ma
forse se faccio qualcosa di positivo
posso lo stesso influenzare e la
risposta è esattamente così
sapete che un'attività fisica moderata
ovviamente perché stiamo parlando di
mamma in gravidanza ma un'attività
fisica moderata regolare durante la
gravidanza è in grado di aumentare le
capacità cognitive della prole
molto probabilmente perché si riduce la
produzione di molecole infiammatorie che
hanno un impatto negativo sul cervello e
sullo sviluppo del del piccolo e quindi
questa cosa importantissima noi possiamo
cominciare a costruire la riserva
cognitiva dei nostri figli alla quale
poi attingeranno durante la loro vita e
che sarà importante per resistere alle
malattie anche dell'invecchiamento
fino da quando sono nella nostra pancia
ed è chiaro che per noi ormai troppo
tardi purtroppo però non è tardi per i
nostri figli non è tardi per i nostri
nipoti questo è un messaggio importante
che possiamo portare a casa e nel
frattempo gli scienziati lavorano nel
frattempo gli scienziati cercano di
trovare farmaci che blocchino la
malattia che l'ha blocchino davvero ma
nel frattempo noi possiamo fare queste
cose
e questo è un modo che ci dà se vogliamo
un po la speranza è che ci può far
arrivare un po più preparati e forse
anche un pochino meno spaventati a
questo fatidico 2050 grazie